[Music]
hello and welcome friends to peppers
place
it's gaming wig epic fun time smash like
for gaming wig today we're playing
papers please
jack told me this game gets used I like
those
so we were playing papers please I of
course have played this game before so I
know how to play game it's game of as
being border guard
a congratulations to your cooperation
I want a labor lottery and now I
menstruation my name is Paul excellent
for immediate placement 3 for 2 minutes
3 administer ok the Greyston border
check my grass the important tag point
what that's the most dangerous good
whose checkpoint in all of arid stoltski
I did get apartment from family glory to
add tadka
glory to the mother poopie what am I say
I don't know November 23rd now the rule
e temple of this game inspector welcome
to new position of blastin border
control okay stampers per entry visa
uh-huh ok deny all foreign air factor
I Spit on the foreigner glory to
arstotzka next day appears finally here
in return is La Cava Antonia hmm what a
beautiful picture a Brewer with all
tadka approved enjoy have gluten and
vodka welcomes next da svidaniya
ok let's go Ian let's see ok no get the
du Midi Eric Scott scans only don't
waste my time
I have family too come on how long am I
going to do this accent that it's so bad
I waited in this damn night eight hours
I hope it was worth it well too bad you
ugly snake
you can't come at a stud guns only get
out of my face unbelievable you spit I
Spit on disgusting what about you
nice receding hairlines okay oh what a
picture midnight
bye bye bye bye have your documents
ready mixed oh he appears it was a
mistake
you waited eight hours to tell me that
pathetic papers please
all right it's an artist obscure
passport okay alright
mr. Orry Viet one I mean who knows
whatever you're a prude get out of my
face enjoy it
check out the punter glorious okay we
have whamon alright okay though you
waste my time woman you not only waste
my time you waste other people time next
be appears at its thoughts can approve
enjoy enjoy your time so the thing with
this game is that it gets more and more
difficult as you go there's new
requirements that will change and you're
incentivized to get as many people pass
as possible but at the same time if you
make a mistake you'll pay the penalty
it's a really interesting game it's a
really surprisingly fun game if anyone
came and pitched to me like hey hey
there's this game where you play as a
border guard I would be like that sounds
lame but it's actually a really fun now
obviously the first stage is really easy
at least that's how I remember it we
really just deny all the foreigners well
you look amazing
and who I almost am yes oopsie
whole much made oopsie at least don't
get on me how many we have 11 papers
arrest Otsuka oh you can go you can go
hurry glory to arstotzka we got 12
Aegina sets Jean la vie not sense today
we don't need we sleep so you manage
your budget based on I don't know I
don't remember November 24th is a new
day new opportunities ok all right ok ok
checkpoint all passports information
carefully for descriptions is deny any
entrant with inconsistent information
you see now we have to use my mind user
in spectrum or using the red button and
your - ok so we have to highlight what
the problems are
ok ok glory to arstotzka inspector
politics neeext NYX come on open for
business papers Krista so now we have to
lock is it expired
no yet female the glory to arstotzka
cause no trouble yet you'll see here if
you make a mistake ok where she was fine
let's see
aunt agrea what are you doing you spit
in my face
this is expired it has expired
interrogation I cannot enter I just
renew it too bad you will never know
this country next get the real passport
give me the goddamn Priapus okay 1980
mm-hmm Mel you don't look like man with
this this question sorry ma'am no
discrimination
I just what is this question what do you
mean I don't know okay it's not expired
or there okay approved enjoy Paris not
sky welcomes everyone as long as you
meet the requirements papers give it to
me our maid Nicole okiya female akhiya
okay I care she looks a very strange on
the picture next I think I'm Way too
slow here I notice Peter no no what I do
invalid issuing country safety hello
handsome
you look bored if you want a good time
yeah for gamers okay thank you
so para disma what would what did oh god
I don't I can't believe I messed up
unbelievable
it's part of the game I guess you're
approved you can go
I'll be around a couple months don't
forget to visit listen I can barely
afford food please oh nice scarf sir is
is there map what happened
oh god someone's trying to run LLL shoot
alright so here we go this is the
problem I did oh my god
alright so the problem is Kreskin is
easy okay we did it that was a good day
I think that was very good in taste
productive okay good yeah we need
medicine her son I don't think we have
to save money I don't have time for
medicine for children okay verify
information yeah yeah missing documents
mm-hmm
rule book okay okay let's check the
rulebook really great because so we had
C these are the only districts allowed
in this area so if we're real trihard
we'll check all the issuing countries I
think we have to do that okay open
reappears I guess at the end I will so
this is a bristan lawrence mail okay you
can go what tell us this all they need
an entry ticket as well I didn't even
read that
next oh they need about all foreigners
need a ninja's again okay well clearly
what do you mean no correlation how do I
ask her about the ant how do I ask about
the entry ticket okay she has an entry
ticket it's valid from 1980 to 11 okay
that's today
god dammit stop giving me stuff okay I'm
too slow I'm too slow I know okay god I
female I don't expiry you can go come to
pink I don't ask for other please next
I'm too slow
next please my son will die okay
well it starts cat doesn't need 1983
parodies nah dah welcome come on come on
don't waste my time looking uh huh
terrorist attack you lucky have jobs it
was not my fault
take restarts Cape welcome everyone we
have good time here very nice
oh very nice república one moment right
this is wrong entry
valid on deny deny
it add my prayer she tried to waste my
time mer Galerius male okay all looks
good it all looks good entry welcome
next come on we need ten at least glory
to arstotzka the greatest country in the
world all the countries are give me the
king ding hello to proceed use inspector
mode to interrogate review page 2 of
today's bulletin there we go oh I see
Eddy Scott's got so great passport not
required right okay okay I come back
again yeah
oh my god I wasted so much time
well she from collegia whether that's
correct
female you have to check yet very good
glory to arstotzka the greatest country
in the world
give me the goddamn papers alright first
let's check this it's valid gray yarko
City I remember your Co City
I'm very nice during winter can hardly
feel my toes your your Co City what what
ha ha your acoustic day what is your Co
City your passport fault information I
will shoot you I do not understand you
don't understand
well understand this I do I Spit on you
and your mother
bye-bye no one will get past the
greatest border guard of all time
through p2p my son is sick
oh my study see yet we don't have time
to be sick my son
useless does my son parent yet my son
wait I didn't read they must show an ID
card foreigners must secure an entry
parent
ok entry tickets are no longer service
they need an entry permit duration of
stay ok ok ok so enter must have a
passport they must have current must
have an ID card citizens must have
antique are foreigners requiring entry
permits so this is the entry permit so
we gotta cross examine these two and
enter by well what the [ __ ] is this
oh it matches all right well I am stupid
then oh that's okay wait you entered too
early is that not a descriptions
discrepancy why I got a bad feeling
about this
you're not denied your denied I don't
like his face protocol violated so even
if you deny you can do it wrong alright
I guess they can enter by any fidon't
three months scar there's so much to
check now
Olga Zara now okay okay
visit three months I don't understand um
female okay the only thing I haven't
checked this the city but I think it's
correct
I remember Sookie neck oh no trouble
can't believe I got a warning this is
the is awful give me the goddamn papers
no yeah shut up okay and three tickets
what is the permit oh my god nyet
go back to your car I don't care you
paid use money for taking I don't care I
really don't care oh my god you're ugly
oh okay Diane all Diane oh you think you
can get me in there get these name don't
match don't waste my you have two
different oh let's watch fingerprint
give me this her name is a key Diane
Amna okay it says you don't have two
names why the names don't match my name
changed recently is there a way to check
that don't waste time go hey hey oh I
forgot hopefully I didn't do wrong I
don't know I'm trying it's very hard
very stressful yeah that's the purpose
of the trip I'm so happy that border
opened I visit son I have not seen him
six months okay Luke obscure Alexandre
Luke obscure okay enter okay
duration well yeah now I got it I'm an
idiot you it expired please let me pass
my son waiting oh my son waiting bye-bye
I'll tell your son his mother is a cow
okay come on paper please Alan Novick
citizens Marika ID card where oh there
is this never mind
okay uh my god what is this
why the name difference why name
different I have two different name well
we'll be the double of check of that
okay
roar Nora yeah yeah interrogate please
let me through
come back when you're not a [ __ ]
yes this is fun come on come on papers
what's purpose work okay to reaction
twelve weeks
okay hi hun don't recognize hi hon what
is high-end huh
okay hi I'm fine nineteen aha okay okay
work okay hmm enjoy your time in
glorious country Cosmo travel knee axe
ah what I didn't belly name no no it
hurts
god dammit pre-approved okay okay let's
play a lot
where's entry permit is he gonna give us
an entry permit and it starts get still
best country for sure I like this guy
one day you'll make it okay okay you not
like Passport I understand I come back
again with better water and it starts k
welcome papers okay la Tosca again okay
la TomSka female 19 oh yeah okay there's
even the hi to look at and then wait
there's so much to look at they just
require an ID card right I think that's
fine Laurie it starts again oh my god
what oh god I suck at this game my son
is gonna die now my son is sick in head
my dirty dick shut up I make mistake at
work son don't get medicine so what okay
I will try not to suck so bad this time
okay glory to arstotzka what what's the
news
you are now authorized to detain
interrogate description please enable
the tension the tension I think it's
this one right which one is the tension
shouter counter
okay next
foreigners work ing permit citizen ID
card one year okay that's correct
wait what did she say work okay that's
correct
Passport what a lovely picture oh yeah
ah okay interrogation what is your
problem what why you waste my time what
do you mean check it again hahahahaha oh
the gulag we send her to Siberia and you
will pay the crime of wasting my time at
its thought sky glory to arstotzka 176
okay so I am taller than crane yeah
birthday okay grounded seaman appear
1983 okay okay looks good right Alton
district Alton Alton I okay I think I
think you can enter yes enjoy please
don't mess up
god this give a stressful day I think
our what's the purpose transit okay how
long couple weeks I guess
is that a description I'm being very
picking it matching okay
okay let's check the name list rod Vince
okay let's check the number okay okay
okay
1982 okay
Oh enter by now I get I'm so stupid and
less Brandi this is a Republican right
yeah
let's less than Maddie okay okay okay
everything good have a great time and
smiles great time and smiles god I hope
I don't mess up okay nice hair
glory to arstotzka papers Samar and rock
Samar and rock okay what is your problem
you have two differently why does
everyone have two different names all
right do this in the meantime I'll look
at everything else no known I'll know no
Nile what is your problem what are you
doing oh sorry it's technical problem
shoot him okay papers please don't waste
time what's purpose of trade it's not my
choice I'm just duration of stay a
little as possible you piece of [ __ ]
fine I have to do my job where is this
from United Federation pathetic Krista
okay what's your name Nicholas Palermo
okay 1945 doesn't say expire okiya okiya
okay what one second one second what's
the seal hmm what is this seal oh never
mind
fine you may enter god they like pink in
these countries Sunday what's the
purpose transit okay
duration two weeks dialog ski-doo stone
enter bye
okay okay
West Gradstein
again I think it's so nerve-wracking I
really want to do a good job for my son
that will die papers come on papers
what's the purpose visit okay how long
okay
1934 okay okay yeah Makayla lindahl
that's gotta be reference is another
developer Swedish and this is a Swedish
name okay let's check anti-gay yeah okay
yeah I think this is all fine yeah of
course welcome to beautiful country all
right I think they did a thing with a
Kickstarter right that you could be a
character in the game actually I don't
know if that's true you look beautiful
good day good day to you mr. roasted
pewter finally become free again I don't
care what stock pewter okay what was his
reason emigrate okay forever
good for you forever Wow
enter bye okay is there a problem yet no
problem sent Marie memo what about if I
can trying to find something to bust
these guys on he's fine
you're fine enjoy please be kind to my
wife she's okay hello Pierre purse
did you see my where there where he is
where is your entry permit where is it
don't waste my time
get him I have to detain her I don't
care you need entry permit don't waste
my time you have doomed me bye-bye
I thought I could detain her oh my son
is sick maybe he needs to grow up
get some balls yeah
jobs few becoming fewer what's a
glorious day in Aries thoughts guy I
love my work
all right the minutes later has
instituted a special program to control
immigrant labor travelers entering for
work require a valid work pass okay how
does that look like documents work pants
okay so they need one of those seals so
entrance must have passport they must be
current must have ID for this required
entry permit workers must have a work
that's okay glorious day artist Otsuka
papers come on
what pass work okay duration ruler
mr. Adam save Vika Torah Adam say Vika
Torah okay okay okay okay
this is fine in the work permit it's
okay right
what is this oh it is correct
he's from república nyet
he's from import da hai ban hai okay
hi Nagesh image show show engaged sports
yokas Oh Adam a car there's so many
things to look at now have your
documents ready come on paper this place
was purpose plan to work duration six
months da Oh yet
not interested Michaela John of 'no i
okay does it have the seal okay
seal what is this place integrity yeah
what is this place a barista skull okay
expire okay
wet wet where is your entry permit
others okay
all nighter okay okay okay
very good enjoy our city good times
please help me what is this a name dari
olodum promised me and my sister good
work I do not trust him
I'm afraid he will take away my passport
first me to work brother please - son I
don't have time this is not my job
immigrating forever vicar Sam Alexander
Alexander bickerson Vickers ham Vickers
ham what a stupid name you look
mercury's what country is this
Republican yet aunt agree yet nyet nyet
nyet nyet nyet
o briston da but what is marry Gary yes
what is this the city is incorrect I
have no idea
detained detain them take them away next
L don't white matter
welcome glory to arstotzka what is
purpose transit okay couple days okay
Rubina Svetlana hmm okay oh okay okay
not every day I approve someone No
invalid expiration they goddamn it why
didn't you not tell me
god this you again this looks good
but I'm sorry you need you need entry
permit I'm sorry he actually has a good
one for one
oh man you funny guy now I need the
entry permit why you're on very strict
border that this good job job right I
looked everything and come back the
patience of this guy I love it
one day one day he'll make it through
papers please oh my god where's the
passport they took away my passport he
hasn't temporary visa oh so it's just to
deny him interesting that is thoughts
can foreigners recording it citizens ID
card okay God you keep giving me this
stuff Ludum daddy and what is suspicious
photo 1946 their rate n is 179 no okay
I'm fine 81-kilo okay and you expire we
don't have a problem unless unless I
need to learn like you save so much time
it wins once you learn the city's glory
to arstotzka whenever I have proved
someone I feel like ah like that yeah
Paris because when you deny you know for
sure you better right okay we know
that's right now we remember that so if
they are heavier than normal it means
they're carrying contraband so we get to
inspect them later I remember it
baya this looks fine no what is this the
date don't match
I've no idea what you're talking about
detain detain sender to Siberia next
glory to arstotzka papers work pass okay
duration twelve weeks okay
1983 okay
oh sorry
[ __ ] where's his passport okay there's
so much to look at now God your Co City
I think that's correct your Co City da
mail okay sure
Luckman Lockman Stefan Lachman health
care okay it's Stefan I think I think
everything is so okay no no that's fine
that's fine
lucky you you get a proven have a great
time oh he made it
okay papers why does he look so weird
you will visit friends 60 days
why I don't press that what happened
no goddamn it your son is sick and needs
medicine
move upgrade press space to toggle
inspect mode well I need I need I can't
afford I guess I'll get heating glorious
day I love my one yeah okay let's check
out the inspect book search all before
approving their entry because of the
bombing yesterday ok glorious day no
yeah ok so now we can respect them ok
this goddamn City couple months sciency
what she said visiting that's correct
enter bye ok ok
Alberta demacia Damacio ok missing ok
so rolls the rules he said all
collections must be searched I'm
pressing space how do I search you we
selected you for a random search a
random search totally random turn
towards scanner I think this is now we
get to see some filthy colleague here ah
Lavinia well you are fined up you should
not see this I save this
welcome to collect yeah I mean arstotzka
neeext haha papers
kaliesha we have selected you visit we
have selected you for a random search
that's crazy we never do this random
completely random evade or expire yeah
I will not save this okay very well you
are a proof glory to arstotzka I think
we're doing pretty good papers please
goddamn collections we have selected you
two weeks okay this is crazy you will
never do this I swear
completely random Jacquelyn Colonel
weather I remember bed or
oh but will not save this expiry enter
by Colonel Jacqueline okay glory to
arstotzka I want to deny someone come on
stop being good papers come on
my glorious arrest was submitted to
Kayla one on this industry okay okay
Switzer camera hmm okay or avec runner
it's all okay
I think burnt on district like I did
something wrong here I'm just gonna try
and speed it up
invalid gender what the hell was that
then I should have checked stupid it's
the only thing I didn't check where's
your [ __ ] passport now I'm getting
pissed off you don't have it Oh
valina damn Pope's Chaya
nineteen enter by female fine got a
check though God damages are so many
things to check the United Federation
Christa da these correct da transit
couple days this one is fine this one
for sure is fine the real question is
who checks the checker right yeppers
this is crazy
we never do this huh okay
Olga - Shin skaia transit but what is
this detention okay there we go
no weapons what are you doing you made
the mistake good saying what is wrong
with people
nice mustache this is crazy this is
crazy we never do this I've never seen
this in my job the ratio to stay a
couple of weeks visiting friends visit
ok very tiny peepee very tiny filthy
small peepee collections no weapons
goddammit it's in the way what are you
doing
you made a mistake Nani slow down my
friend I'll give you ten credits you
cannot bribe an officer of various
thoughts can they must be neeext
papers purpose transit couple weeks okay
ba ba ba ba ba ba
teshia Jen rush texia generation female
Loren dress
what is Loren dress
I don't recognize why do I not recognize
[ __ ] I forgot which one are any Lauren
does okay fine expire 1984 I think she's
okay
enter by 19 yep
okay fine enjoy it's so much scarier to
approve okay this is the last one trains
it time to 14-day transit correct enter
by correct correct correct beautiful men
I want to let him through this is no yet
God why does it go back all the way hi
hon we might as well not if there's a
1943 male expire I think this one is
okay
welcome to glorious country my son is
dying so that is our first day in
glorious era starts can
son is sick boo-hoo-hoo I don't care why
should I care
we're running really low on everything
my everyone's hungry
my hunk oh this is great thank you for
watching this episode of gaming week
very epic and very nice smash like for
gaming we buy all the merch and I see
you tomorrow glory to arstotzka what you
never played to / simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]